Working for the SCP Foundation can be a frightening
endeavor, but not all the anomalies they encounter
are violent, vicious monsters all intent on
destruction.
SCPs can often be as lost, lonely and sad
as the rest of us sometimes feel.
In that spirit, let’s take a heart-breaking
and tear-jerking journey through some of the
saddest SCPs, that might even make you cry.
Get those tissues ready and don’t say we
didn’t warn you.
To the untrained observer, SCP-348 is just
an ordinary white bowl, with a blue flower
pattern painted on its ceramic surface.
The Chinese lettering on its side translates
to the phrase ‘thinking of you’.
However, if anyone suffering from a minor
injury – like a scraped knee, a cut, or
a bruise – or any other mild ailment is
presented with the bowl, its anomalous properties
will begin to show.
SCP-348 will fill itself with soup, usually
varying in ingredients, but consistently enjoyed
by those that have eaten from it.
Finishing the soup, though, that’s what
can start the waterworks.
After someone consumes the contents of SCP-348,
a message will appear within the bowl, seemingly
coming from the subject’s own father.
In one such instance, a young boy of six,
who had been recently injured whilst playing
with his friends, was given SCP-348 to eat
from.
The boy’s parents were divorced, and his
father no longer living at home.
When the child ate the soup, the message in
the bowl read ‘I’m sorry, son.’
Another similar test was run by the Foundation
using SCP-348, this time with an older boy
of eleven years old, who was suffering from
a cold.
He had also been adopted by a foster family
prior, and the message that appeared after
he had eaten said ‘I’m glad you’re happy.’
When testing the effects of SCP-348 on adults,
less of them felt inclined to finish the soup
in the bowl.
One of these much older subjects, a forty-year-old
woman with a sore throat, had become estranged
from her parents after moving away from home.
However, she would frequently send them money
and eventually helped arrange senior housing
for her parents, until her father passed away.
While she initially remarked that her soup
tasted bitter, it was fulfilling by the end
of the meal.
The note left by SCP-348 simply said ‘Thank
you.’
Once, a test was conducted involving SCP-348
and a sixty-year-old man who was suffering
from a terminal illness.
The grandfather to many grandchildren was
offered the bowl of soup and delightedly ate
it, claiming it was the best soup he had ever
tasted.
It gave him a sense of satisfaction and even
eased some of the pain caused by his illness.
A week later, the old man passed away peacefully
in his sleep.
Oh, what’s that?
Those sweet soup messages weren’t wholesome
enough to encourage even a few sobs.
Okay then, you heartless little monster, we’ll
step up our game with SCP-3017.
Now, you might be forgiven for thinking that
this is a particularly monstrous SCP, after
all, that is his anomalous effect.
Fraisure Melbrook is – or rather, was – an
otherwise ordinary man afflicted with an infectious
cognitohazard.
This would alter the perception of anyone
around Fraisure or any person who might have
spoken to him, and made them believe that
he belonged in custody.
People would be compelled to think that Fraisure
was a dangerous, violent individual, but with
no actual proof that he was.
In many cases, anyone exposed to his cognitohazard
would even try to lock him up themselves.
The one reprieve, however, was that a number
of Fraisure’s immediate family and close
friends were immune to this effect.
Either this was through experiencing prolonged
exposure to SCP-3017, or by simply knowing
him well enough to have context that canceled
out the false beliefs that he was a violent
criminal with an extensive record.
Designated as SCP-3017-1s, the people closest
to him remained unaffected, and Fraisure was
able to maintain healthy relationships with
all of them… until SCP-3017 fell into the
hands of the Foundation.
Arrested and placed in containment, thanks
to the anomalous effect of SCP-3017, the Foundation
believed that Fraisure Melbrook had close
ties and connections to multiple Groups of
Interest.
They began to relentlessly, torturously interrogate
Fraisure, threatening his family unless he
gave them the answers to their questions;
information that he simply could not provide.
He hadn’t even heard of the GOIs the Foundation
wanted to know about, let alone had any direct
affiliation with them.
But still, they kept pressing him, keeping
him locked up and not allowing him to see
his family even when his grandmother developed
lung cancer.
Treated with suspicion and hostility non-stop
every day, SCP-3017 would get one last shot
at freedom, however.
Researcher Rylan, who had been studying Fraisure’s
anomalous properties, as well as a security
officer that had been assigned to watch Melbrook,
both developed the same immunity to the prisoner’s
cognitohazard as his family and friends had.
Working together, they were able to spring
SCP-3017 from Foundation custody, and Rylan
took him back home to see his family.
Little did either of them know of the tragedy
that awaited them.
In a cruel twist of fate, a house fire had
set Melbrook’s family home ablaze, claiming
the lives of his parents, both brothers, his
sister, grandmother, and even his fiancé.
Utterly devastated and overwhelmed with grief,
the loss of his loved ones completely broke
Fraisure.
He had spent so much of his life persecuted,
accused of heinous crimes and arrested despite
being completely innocent.
And as if that wasn’t bad enough, he’d
fought his way free from the Foundation, only
to find his home reduced to ash the day before
he made it back.
By the time the SCP Foundation arrived to
re-capture him, it was already too late.
Fraisure was dead and Researcher Rylan turned
herself over without resistance.
The Foundation soon realized what they had
done, how they had tortured an innocent man
who didn’t actually have the information
they thought he did.
In quiet shame, they reclassified SCP-3017
under a new object class: ‘Neutralised’.
Feeling teary yet?
Maybe a little moist around the eyes?
Oh, those are just your allergies?
Of course they are, how could we be so silly.
Alright, let’s move on.
Taking a step back from the grim, dark reality
for a moment, let’s instead delve into a
world of fantasy.
SCP-1762 was a seemingly ordinary carboard
box, spray-painted silver with the words ‘Here
Be Dragons’ written on it in permanent marker.
Usually, it remained empty, but would occasionally
open, releasing dozens of tiny origami dragons
that would fly out after black smoke had plumed
out of the box.
It was no doubt a sight to behold, the kind
of fantastical occurrence that is inherently
filled with childlike wonder.
Often, a written or carved message would be
left behind after the origami dragons flew
back into their box; and this is how the Foundation
was able to learn of the terrible misfortune
known as ‘The Jabberwocky Event.’
The paper dragons existed in a world of Fantasy,
all contained within the cardboard box.
When they first emerged, the message they
left greeted someone who had seemingly created
the box and its fantastical contents, or had
at least interacted with it before; possibly
a particularly imaginative child with the
reality-bending capability to give life to
the inanimate paper dragons.
The origami creatures seemed to mistake the
Foundation for this original child rediscovering
them after an extended period of time.
They made mention of the existence of other
mystical beings in their world, including
Giants, Elves, Centaurs, and more.
Through their subsequent messages, it appeared
something about the world of SCP-1762 was
gradually becoming unstable, though.
It required imagination to sustain it, to
stabilize the Fantasy within the box.
But unfortunately, the Foundation personnel
examining SCP-1762 refused to accept the existence
of this world.
They instead leaned on science, cold, hard
facts, not the whimsy of the imaginary.
When opening the box, all they saw was its
empty interior, so to them, the Fantasy wasn’t
real.
It was the SCP Foundation’s own lack of
belief, their refusal to make-believe, that
was gradually killing the world inside SCP-1762.
Through their notes, still unaware that they
weren’t speaking with their child creator,
the origami dragons pleaded for aid.
Cries that fell on the Foundation’s deaf
ears.
Within the box, a magical war broke out between
the various creatures inside, with the survivors
fleeing for their lives.
The box itself was effectively a portal, linking
reality with this realm of Fantasy.
It existed in a time when the myths and legends
of old were indeterminable from fact.
SCP-1762 had once represented a physical bond,
a relationship between those two worlds, but
as time had moved on, belief in legends, in
Fantasy, had all but dwindled.
As the world inside the box fell into chaos,
becoming more and more unstable, the words
‘Here Be Dragons’ were burned away from
the carboard surface.
In their final message, the dragons mentioned
they hoped to escape to a new world, concluding
with:
“We are sad.
We love you.
We will not Forget you.
We are scared.
Will You Forget Us?”
Soon after, the box returned to its original
state, with the phrase ‘Here Were Dragons’
on the side, marking the end of the Jabberwocky
Event, and potentially, the Fantasy within
SCP-1762, forever.
From mystical, magical tales of sadness, we
now turn to a sad story from within the ranks
of the Foundation itself.
SCP-451, formerly a field agent working in
the Foundation, seems to an outside observer
to be little more than the average man in
his thirties.
Well, as average as someone working for the
Foundation can be.
But let’s turn things around, if we were
to look from SCP-451’s perspective, how
would he see us?
That’s just the thing… he wouldn’t,
he can’t see us, or anyone else for that
matter.
You see, for a time, this agent was declared
missing in action by the SCP Foundation.
The last recorded assignment he was sent on
was an attempt to retrieve a dangerous anomalous
artifact.
However, this attempt ultimately failed, and
SCP-451 resurfaced a month later at Site 19.
Although, from his point of view, the entire
Foundation facility was empty.
He was the last man on Earth, or so he thought,
at least.
Some unknown influence had permanently altered
the agent’s perception; he had been rendered
incapable of perceiving other human beings.
Now, if you’re a bit of a hermit who prefers
their own company, then this might initially
sound like heaven.
Never having to experience another awkward
interaction with another person; like when
you’re walking down the street, and someone’s
walking towards you, then you have to try
to figure out which way they’re going to
go so you can step in the opposite direction
and avoid bumping into them.
Then you inevitably to that weird shuffle
when you both go to walk the same way.
It’s a whole thing.
Well, as good as it might sound to be rid
of happenings like that, imagine if you couldn’t
see or hear anyone.
Any attempts the rest of the world made to
communicate with you, not one of them registering.
But it was somehow worse than that.
Thanks to his newfound surroundings, or lack
thereof, SCP-451 believed that by interacting
with the anomalous artifact, he had single-handedly
wiped out the entire human race.
The guilt of that action, although only true
from his perspective, weighed heavily on SCP-451’s
conscience.
He spent a lot of time wandering the corridors
of Site 19, overwhelmed by his apparent isolation.
Eventually, the loneliness of his newfound
condition, coupled with the fallacious knowledge
that he had killed the entire human race,
drove him to a state of near madness.
But there would be no escape from this new
state of perpetual hell.
Not only did the condition appear to be incurable,
at least from what he was capable of doing,
but he would not even find solace in death.
He had been cursed with some kind of sadistic
immortality, and it seemed like the only way
to ever connect with others was when they
themselves were near death.
As for what the Foundation were doing to help
SCP-451?
Well, nothing.
There’s little that can do to reverse the
change.
He was a valuable field agent to them before
it happened, and it’s their hope that he
can be again if the process is somehow reversed.
Until then, SCP-451 is forced to live out
this painful existence, spending every day
– as far as he can tell – alone.
Of course, if SCP-451 could wish for anything
in his predicament, it might be something
as simple as some company.
If only there was an SCP that granted the
user their ultimate wish, fulfilled any fantasy,
made them the hero of their own story.
Well, that happens to be the function of SCP-1230.
It appears as a green, hardcover book with
no discernible labels on the spine, nor on
either front or back covers.
The pages are almost entirely blacnk, save
for one simple phrase on the first one: ‘A
hero is born.’
Anyone that reads this page of SCP-1230 won’t
experience any effects immediately, in fact,
its anomalous properties don’t become apparent
until the reader falls asleep.
When they do, they will experience a vivid
dream that can last anywhere from forty-five
seconds to… well, let’s just say considerably
longer.
Although the reader will never be asleep for
any longer than they normally would be.
In their dream, the reader will be the protagonist
within their own fantasy world.
The entire time, they remain fully aware of
their surroundings, their senses and faculties
all work as they would as if they were awake.
Not unlike the Fantasy world of SCP-1762,
the dream worlds experienced by test subjects
who read SCP-1230 vary depending on the imagination
of the dreamer.
Additionally, once they re-emerge from their
slumber, they will be able to recall all the
events of the dream down to every last detail.
Every dream induced by reading SCP-1230 will
also feature a character known only as the
Book Keeper, a friendly, bearded old man in
a green cloak who is apparently the personification
of the book itself.
The role of the Book Keeper seems to be to
create the ‘fantasy-scapes’ as he calls
them, and seemingly creates these bespoke
worlds on behalf of all the dreamers he encounters,
in accordance with their own deepest desires
and wants.
By now, you’re no doubt thinking, how could
this possibly be a sad SCP?
I bet you probably even want a go with SCP-1230
yourself, don’t you?
And who wouldn’t?
After all, you would get to be placed in a
fantasy-scape where you can do anything and
everything you can think of.
On top of that, this isn’t Inception.
Dying or being harmed in one of these dreams
doesn’t translate to real-world death…
well, not directly anyway.
Remember when we mentioned the dreams can
last a ‘considerably long’ time; at least
in their own, internal fantasy-scape time.
Well, here’s what makes it one of the saddest
SCPs on this list, maybe even ever.
Imagine getting to live out a fantasy adventure
as the hero, the main protagonist in your
own story.
Picture you spent a number of years in that
dream time, experiencing every event of that
story, that world firsthand.
It looks real, it feels real; for the time
that you’re there, at least.
So, what happens when you wake up?
How are you going to feel if you’re all
of a sudden pulled out of that fantasy and
dropped back into the mundanity of real life?
Would you prefer your fantasy to the real
world?
And what would it do to you if you couldn’t
go back?
This was experienced firsthand by one of the
Foundation’s researchers, known only as
Professor B. He had specifically requested
the Foundation to allow him to read SCP-1230,
and was giddy with excitement when it came
to be his turn.
Like many others, he read the first page,
seeing ‘A hero is born’ and then instantly
went to sleep, unwilling to wait until later,
clearly eager to get experience his very own
fantasy-scape.
Professor B was asleep for the next twenty-four
hours before the Foundation’s security personnel
were forced to attempt to wake him up.
When they did, he looked around, confused
to be unceremoniously returned to real life.
It was almost as if the amount of time he
had spent within the Book Keeper’s dream
world had caused him to momentarily forget
his old life with the Foundation.
However, he soon regained his memory after
a brief reminder from fellow staff.
But it was never the same after that.
Professor B had experienced the life he always
dreamed of within his dreams, and upon waking,
he had been returned to a life where he was
an aging, tired man in a dead-end job at the
Foundation.
He was no hero here. he was just another nobody.
And the sadness was too much for him.
Professor B passed away not long after.
After this tragedy, the Book Keeper was utterly
distraught.
Through the medium of the book, he left a
note for the personnel of the SCP Foundation.
It read:
“I’m so sorry.
I never intended for this to happen.
I just wanted to make people happy.”
A number of weeks passed before the Foundation
was able to make contact with the Book Keeper
again.
Leaving a note that requested a conversation
with the entity, a Foundation doctor experienced
a dream that was set in a dark, featureless
void.
There, he encountered the Book Keeper, crying
to himself.
When questioned about what had happened to
Professor B, the embodiment of SCP-1230 explained:
“He had such an active imagination!
I was able to create a vast and beautiful
universe for him and it was obvious that he
had wanted a life like that for so long.
He conquered foul beasts and rescued princesses…
He built kingdoms and even raised a family…
but he never wanted to leave.
He delved so far into his fantasy world that
I soon realized he preferred his dream over
the real world.
I reminded him that this was all merely an
illusion, but he wouldn’t listen to me.
I tried to keep him happy for as long as I
could…”
Remember when we mentioned the dreams can
last a ‘considerably long’ time?
(At least in their own, internal fantasy-scape
time).
Professor B had been living out his ultimate
fantasy adventure for two-hundred years, while
only a full day’s worth of time had passed
in the real world.
Having to live through all that, only to wake
up and realize none of it was real was perhaps
too existentially overwhelming for the Professor.
Then again, maybe he had just preferred the
world of his fantasy-scape much more than
the world around him.
And finally, that brings us to one of the
most infamous anomalies in the Foundation’s
extensive history.
SCP-096, better known as the Shy Guy, is a
terrifying, towering creature with a hairless
body, sunken eyes and a huge, gaping mouth.
But don’t you ever get the sense that there’s
something inherently…
sad about SCP-096?
Insecurity is something a lot of us experience,
and have to face every day.
But the Shy Guy’s is taken to such an extreme
degree.
He can’t bear the thought of anyone looking
at him.
It’s so bad for him, causes him to experience
so much distress that he has to travel lighting
fast to anyone that looks at his face.
Once he’s caught up with them and killed
them, then he’s right back to his usual
routine: sobbing and weeping, or pacing around
his cell.
Perhaps his story isn’t as sad as some of
the others on this list, but we do know it’d
be a welcome change if someone could make
the Shy Guy smile, just for a little while.
Now go check out “25 MOST FRIGHTENING SCPS”
and “WHAT’S THE SCARIEST SCP?”
if you’d like to replace that sadness with
some good, old-fashioned fear!